[音楽]
ん
tan
pa
ブーブーケースに入れるようになったよ
俺もマッチだブーブー今めちゃくちゃいろんなにょそう
最強のベイベー度作ってもいいんじゃないかと思いましたどれで作ったりボカロ好き
エレベーターをつくって試行錯誤したんですけども私は常にたどり着きまして最強の
ベルトとは何かを
そのベイブレードベイブレードが中いつ自分に接触する部分
ドライバーですばメディアの通りいろいろあるわけなんですけどまぁこういうところが
攻めにぶつかるわけなんでここの形によってねどういう動きがするかが決まりますがて
ねこういうメタルボールだったらすごい回転しやすかったりこういうゴムグループだっ
たら持久力はないんですけどもすごい攻撃的な動きをしたりこれとかもそうですね
攻撃的な動きをしそうです結局ドライバーなんじゃねえかなと思いましてどんだけ覚え
ものをつけたり攻撃的なこの上のパーツを付けたりしてもう結局で止まったら負けなん
ですよビルド止まったら負けなんで結局持久力があるベイブレード一番強いんじゃない
か設定が僕の中にあるので今日はなんと
ああああああ
こちら
労組が秒でございません
あっはぁ
ああああああ
あああああなんでこんな完全なことに気づかなかったんだろう後シンプルに画鋲をこの
ドライバーにつければあんな下とかってたら持久力最強なんですよ10時にが気を
付ければめちゃくちゃ安定して持久力もあって最強のレベル8になるんじゃないかと
思ったので今回が火をつけて
ベレーターゲットいうとは思いますか
うなんかや病院の通算思い出すたさあですぎてもなんかやだから1回切りましょうこれ
をこの自分だけちょっとザマなんで切り落としてみましょう
愛想池剃ってるぞこれ怖い飛んでこないですリーダー reader
ビターなラクダちょっと無くなっちゃうねんなくなりました飛ばないように次は今中で
あります
[音楽]
はいてにで打ちきれいにとれました想像以上に綺麗に取れましたなぁこういう感じで
まぁプラッツになりました骨が実際に使う方ですねあーもう惚れでろ
う事が病気られちゃってああ
それだなあこれ靴ギャそうだねこれにつけていきましょう飽きてきてきた全米の未来が
ここにかかっている
[音楽]
大きな極刑ここにくっつけますまあ何回かにもくっつきそうな感じがするんですけど
ちゃんとね並行ねくっつけたいんだ結構まっすぐじゃないかなこれ調べて待ちましょう
hiding デブチックつきましたこちら
でかいなおそらく体協のドライバーが病ですそれぞれの画面を使って何かベレットを
つくってみましょう
これでどうでしょうかこちら熱中戦となるが妙でファースト意味ために最強の持久力
ネプ2戦となるが秒
どんな祖母見せるのでしょうか学校はこれ大丈夫かなぁ卜部ないとマネしないで
くださいねバーストしてが秒飛んできたら
ます
自分もバーストしますから本当目とか入ったらチョコヘルメットかぶるほんと真似し
ちゃダメですけどこれ目に入ったら本当にヤバイですからね早速回すいこうと思います
本当俺の女の日に範囲内じゃいますツリー
トゥワンゴーシュ突破
あーこわーパワーってこの動きなんかすごいすごい
立方分怪しい怪しい
ええええ
うわぁ
大丈夫かちょっと不安になる動きだったの動きが怪しかったらこう知っ
バーでもすごい安静力はすごいですねー
長いのか何か違うんだよななんかパッと見すごい強そうなんですけどなんか高すぎるん
だよねやっぱり
弱点と者多分高さが高すぎるところです麻生でキロ高さがありすぎるんで挟みニキビ
ます
んをっ
うんはーい
ok な傘があれなんで極限まで削ります
[音楽]
tan
誰と恋さ
いいんじゃない道だ完璧だ早急にかなり通信を捉えたように作りました
これから良いていくと思います321号車
ちゃんとぽいを扱い採点してるよ便でもすごくあれっ
めっちゃ安定してるめっちゃンってしてめちゃんてする中心を捉えたくらいの動きだと
思います一応成功だと思います今一番強いと言われている一角のラグですサイザー
ap ジャイロでめっちゃ強いですよいやー
[音楽]
こいつが今一番強いって言われてそうなのでどこ5と熱演セントラルガードで戦って
みようと思いますこれでどっちが一番強いか決まっていらっしゃる
以上このが最強なんでちょっとハンデで3通1号中
敵が妙しバイヤー自虐
ええええええ
食べるのへどんどん溝いい勝負だいい勝負
いい勝負だよああ
いろいろ you do
いっ
えっ
バーッ
[音楽]
teame
teal
me
ana あああっ